RANI URBAS: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the session
on Google Trust.
We are part of the
Google Cloud Trust Team,
and we work closely
with our customers
to ensure that you can
confidently use our products
and our technologies
from a trust perspective.
Specifically, today will
focus on privacy, security,
and compliance--
both industry best practices
and regulatory mandates--
data integrity, operational
transparency and user control.
In this session, we'll
walk you through how
our Trust Team engages with
customers to achieve this.
We have a very simple
agenda for you today.
The introduction is really
focused on trust in the Cloud
and how that manifests
in everything that we do.
We'll then delve
into the three C's.
And you're probably wondering
what the three C's are.
Without giving too much
away, we hope that we've
piqued your curiosity.
And then we'll wrap by
sharing some resources
on where you can find more
information about Google Cloud
compliance, privacy
and security.
By way of introduction,
my name is Rani Urbas.
I lead the Enterprise
Trust team at Google Cloud.
And as a team, we're responsible
for helping our Enterprise
customers in highly
regulated industries
with their compliance
and privacy and trust
related assessments
and implementations.
We work closely with
our customers globally.
And additionally, we assist
with customer-led audits,
regulator audits--
which includes
data center audits.
I am here with my
colleague Ruchi Khurana.
And Ruchi leads the Google
[INAUDIBLE] Security Risk
program.
And this program is focused on
ensuring the ongoing privacy
and security of
our customer data.
She collaborates with many
of our highly regulated Cloud
Enterprise customers
on engagements
related to trust security,
audit and compliance.
As I mentioned, I am part
of the Trust team at Google,
and our house is
built on four pillars.
The first pillar is
around protection.
Data security is the foremost
in everything that we do.
It is part of our DNA.
You've already heard,
probably, about our layers
of security controls.
Our firewall, VPSC-- our
Virtual Private Cloud Service
Controls--
Cloud Armor, IAM--
Identity and Access Management--
with policy intelligence.
And now, the Cloud
Security Command Center
Premium, with security
health analytics
to help with compliance and
misconfiguration detection.
We've delivered additional
security functionality
with reCAPTCHA,
Enterprise, and Web
Risk, where we prevent ad
attacks, fake account creation,
fraud, malware, phishing--
all that could
impact our customers
and our customers' end uses.
Our second pillar, really,
is around transparency.
The road to trust has to be
built through transparency.
And that transparency has to be
based on accurate and on-demand
information.
And we have built and delivered
features to our customers like
access transparency,
access approvals,
third-party key management
specifically for that reason--
products that enforce
customer control.
Which leads us to
our third point--
control.
We live by the principle that
our customers own their data,
we don't.
You can access it, take
it out at any time.
We have built and
equipped our customers
with tools and technology
to manage access and protect
their data.
And last, but not least,
is Enterprise compliance.
We've built world-class
capabilities
to enable and facilitate
our customers'
compliance with a vast
range of regulatory bodies
around the world.
We invest in achieving
and maintaining
our regulatory certifications
and attestations
for all of our products
across all of our data centers
globally.
So for the purpose of
today's presentation,
we'll be looking at
trust through the lens
of our Enterprise
customer engagements.
And for ease of discussion,
let's talk about it from,
one, a compliance perspective.
two, a commitment perspective.
And 3, the collaboration angle.
Starting with compliance,
our customer-centric approach
to compliance has really
enabled us to view compliance
with a much wider perspective.
So if you look at the
pyramid in front of you,
compliance of Google Cloud.
We deliver foundational
certifications, as well as
industry-specific
certifications,
that addresses multiple
industry segments,
such as public sector, health
care, financial services--
to name a few.
Over the foundation is
compliance in Google Cloud.
We deliver a comprehensive
set of capabilities
to help customers ensure
that their Google Cloud
workloads are always compliant.
Compliance toolkits, where we
deliver a very diverse range
of self-service compliance tools
to help our customers assess,
act and comply with their
regulatory requirements.
So our customers and regulators
expect, as they should,
independent verification
of our security, privacy,
and compliance controls.
And Google undergoes
independent, third-party audits
on a regular basis to
provide this assurance.
This means that an
independent auditor
has examined the
controls present
in our data centers,
our infrastructure
and in operations.
Our certifications
include widely recognized
and internationally-accepted
independent security standards,
including ISO 27001
for security controls,
27017 for Cloud security,
27018 for Cloud privacy--
as well as SOC 1,
SOC 2 and SOC 3.
And these certifications help
us meet the demands of industry
standards also, such
as CSA Star, PCI DSS,
and many other regional
standards as well.
And we continue to expand the
list of our certifications
globally to assist our customers
with their very dynamic
compliance landscape.
Here's a list of some of
the regulatory authorities
that we've engaged,
both unilaterally,
and with our industry peers,
and with our customers.
We're also working on more
compliance products and tool
links to help our customers
streamline and automate
their compliance process
with their regulators.
So moving on, I'm
going to hand this over
to Ruchi, who's going to talk
about the second C in the trust
journey that we're
taking you on.
Over to Ruchi.
RUCHI KHURANA: Thanks, Rani,
for the wonderful introduction
and the summary on
the compliance piece.
Now let's talk
about commitments.
A major part of the
commitments is transparency.
A Cloud providers should
detail how it operates.
At Google, we are
committed towards providing
full transparency of
our security design
choices via multiple artifacts.
A few recent examples include
our overall infrastructure
security, encryption
addressed and encryption
in transit across our platforms.
When you have these types
of detailed documentations,
you can make the
decision yourself
to determine if what we are
doing for security and privacy
is adequate.
Next, a Cloud provider should
provide binding commitments
on how it will operate and
handle your data internally.
These areas of commitment
should include things
like processing restrictions,
business continuity, data
deletion, data incident
notification process,
subprocessor list, and
other security measures.
At Google, we are
transparent and committed
towards all of these ideas.
You can easily find
these commitments
on our data processing
security page.
Now let's talk
about the third C--
that is collaboration, and
it's one of the most important
C's of the Trust.
Talking about
collaboration, at Google,
we offer a suite
of services when
it comes to collaborations.
To start with, we
have a huge team
of specialists who will
help you to understand
Google's GRC [? posture. ?] We
offer workshops and one-to-one
sessions with GRC gurus.
An example would
be understanding
compliance lifecycle at Google.
Secondly, we offer free access
to Google's third-party audit
reports--
which Rani mentioned earlier--
such as ISO, SOC,
FedRAMP, and others.
Thirdly, our teams
work on a multitude
of security and
compliance collaterals
to help you understand and
address common security risks.
Last, but not the
least, we are dedicated
toward supporting
your due diligence
on our third-party risk efforts
in the form of facilitating
your cybersecurity
risk assessments.
Next, let me talk
through collaboration
through audit rights.
At Google, we are
committed to meet
your regulatory and contractual
requirements of right to audit.
We offer all regulated
customers right
to assess us on
security controls.
Moreover, we also offer your
customers, or any users,
transitive right to
audit Google's services
and organization controls.
Secondly, we understand
that your operations may
extend beyond a certain region.
So we offer the right to
inspect a Google data center
for physical and environmental
security controls in whichever
region you are operating.
Thirdly, we are committed to
support any audits that may
be requested by our regulators.
What we have found
is that transparency
is the key when it comes
to working with regulators.
And our teams will work with
you and support any request
with the utmost transparency.
And finally, we also
offer pooled audits,
where multiple institutions
can pull together as one group
to audit Google services
an organization controls.
This approach benefits both
Google and Google customers
in terms of time, resources,
level of effort and audit
depths.
To give an example
of pooled audits,
Google is committed
toward supporting
CCAG pooled audits for European
financial institutions.
These financial
institutions are required
to conduct a comprehensive
risk assessment of their Cloud
providers, to comply with
their regulatory obligations
from regulatory bodies
such as EBA or BaFin.
To optimize on time
and cost of the effort,
these European
financial institutions
work together as a team.
In 2019, we supported
Google's first CCAG audit.
Audit planning and execution
took over six months
from both sides.
Auditors collected over
800=plus documents.
And 175+ Google-ers from from
24 different teams were involved
in supporting this audit.
This shows how committed
we are to pooled audits.
And 2020 pooled audits
is also coming soon.
Now, when we talk about
Auditable Cloud Universe,
or any security
program firstly, there
are many areas of
responsibility.
Starting from the base layer
of securing infrastructure
to going up in the stack
of securing the network,
securing data,
securing applications
or managing
identities and access.
There are also ongoing processes
for security operations,
governance, risk and
compliance management.
At Google, we
provide capabilities
to audit all of the domains that
are relevant for your business
operations.
We have a global team who can
support you in any region--
be it Americas, Europe,
Japan, Asia-Pacific.
We collaborate with local teams
on board policy and industry
to better understand
the regulations
that you are subjected to so
that we can provide the highest
level of services when it comes
to facilitating these audit
requests.
Now here are some
additional resources for you
to learn more about Google's
security compliance and trust
posture.
Thank you so much for
listening to us today.
Hope you learned about how
Google Cloud is building trust
through compliance, commitment
and customer collaborations.
Thank you.
RANI URBAS: Thank you so much.